franchement là
la larme anti-intrusion d'une entreprise
vient de se déclencher
partir vite pour prendre en flag les
cambrioleurs
[Musique]
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauvé secourir protéger finalement j'ai
changé de cap je suis journaliste
et j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ses femmes ordinaires
qui exercent des métiers hors du commun
aujourd'hui je suis à Creil dans ce
qu'on appelle une zone de sécurité
prioritaire je pense que si on repasse
on prendra un ou deux projectile une
zone de sécurité prioritaire et en
commissariat central au quotidien
[Musique]
la région est prospère et au milieu crée
un îlot de pauvreté misère précarité
chômage qui nourrissent une violence
sourde
vous les avez pas présentés vous lui
présenter tout de suite
aujourd'hui direction le nord de la
région parisienne à une demi-heure de la
Gare du Nord au terminus de la ligne D
du RER dans l'Oise
c'est quand même la compagne
super beau le beau du bout de la région
parisienne la troisième couronne déjà la
Picardie
que je vais plonger dans une zette espée
une zone de sécurité prioritaire le
gouvernement en a créé 80 répartis sur
tout le territoire et à la manœuvre à
Creil le commissaire des visionnaire
Jean-Luc taltavu bonjour
merci d'être venu que vous êtes grand
je vous appelle comment vous êtes
commandant vous êtes comment
c'est donc un commissaire de 2m 07 qui
est en charge de la sécurité de ce
morceau de l'Oise qui n'est plus
vraiment une banlieue mais pas encore la
province on peut pas parler d'une
hostilité
féroce contre les forces de l'ordre on
n'est pas pris à partie systématiquement
contrairement à certains endroits où
même quand on ne fait que passer on est
pris à partie alors que là nous on
patrouille on va partout en revanche il
est vrai que sur certains quartiers
quand on interpelle dès lors qu'on
interpelle ça devient pas mal
c'est tendu et ça peut se passer mal
72000 habitants et à longueur d'année
des violences ordinaires faites de
dégradation de malversations d'atteintes
aux personnes la définition parfaite
d'une zone de sécurité prioritaire
depuis fin mars 2013 cette ZSP englobe
quatre communes Creil Montataire
Nogent-sur-Oise et Villers-Saint-Paul
concrètement l'appellation ZSP a permis
au commissaire d'altavules d'obtenir 10
policiers supplémentaires
quand même mais oui mais oui
les bons signes ou les mauvais signes
longtemps l'agglomération de Creil a
figuré dans le top 10 des villes les
plus violentes de France aujourd'hui
elle concentre encore elle seule plus de
40 % des interventions de police du
département
c'est donc dans ce commissariat que je
m'installe pour quelques jours
bonjour bonjour
le chef de poste
pour changer les ampoules
il a sécurité devenue une priorité
nationale mais visiblement en chemin on
a oublié l'éclairage donc là il y a zéro
et moi je furette dans le bureau du
patron
[Musique]
commissaire
vidéo
donc ça c'est votre territoire oui
la particularité c'est qu'elle englobe
toute la circonscription donc la zone de
sécurité pour prix prioritaire c'est
toute votre circonscription tout est
prioritaire
les effets sont un bébé de Manuel Valls
dans les zones difficiles le ministre de
l'Intérieur a voulu renforcer les liens
entre policiers magistrats enseignants
et élus locaux histoire de lutter plus
efficacement contre la délinquance
qu'est-ce que ça a changé le classement
de toute cette zone 75000 habitants en
zone de sécurité prioritaire par le
ministère de l'intérieur ça donne une
priorité dans l'affectation des moyens
donc nous on est plutôt content puisque
ça m'a permis de renforcer ma présence
dans les quartiers le commissaire
altavules dispose désormais de 152
policiers pour veiller sur les quartiers
les cités en fait la Commanderie qui
était tristement célèbre qui avait
l'objet d'un grand grand programme de
rénovation urbaine et le plus
contraignant je dirais c'est le plateau
qui représente facilement la moitié de
la population de Creil
au chevet des aides SP les intervenants
sont nombreux donc là
d'accord
une fois par semaine police nationale et
police municipale et change leurs infos
bonjour merci à tous de votre présence
c'était une semaine très calme enfin je
sais pas si Craig a le même ressenti que
nous
avec la pluie
cette semaine oui j'ai pas d'augmenter
particulière
et en période de calme plat le moindre
tag remonte en haut lieu on a eu un
graffiti qui a été fait à la Mireille et
Martinez donc je pense qu'il va être
enlevé dans les jours qui viennent mais
on a fait une photo on leur cul de même
et ça sera tout pour cette semaine
[Musique]
après cette vue d'ensemble un peu
théorique allons sur le terrain mais
avant ça formalités le gilet par balle
les 357 McDo Bâle chemisé j'ai
énormément de doute
sur l'efficacité de chômage
enfin bon on va faire semblant d'y
croire mais c'est obligatoire question
de sécurité
c'est le groupe de sécurité de proximité
le GSP une sorte de bac de jour qui
m'embarque
la raison d'être du GSP la protection
des personnes et des biens concrètement
ces hommes patrouillent dans
l'agglomération toute la journée à
l'affût de l'infraction
mon guide Bruno 34 ans 50 police
[Musique]
ou pas
cette grise ça vous dit quelque chose
qui a été faite là c'est c'est un break
gris une voiture qui a été faite c'est
une voiture volée dans le jargon
juste à côté
arrivait sur place c'est mon premier
contrôle
en fait il ne s'agit que de mécanique
sauvage cette interdit par la loi d'où
les vérifications d'identité la
palpation mais rien de bien méchant
l'atmosphère est même bon enfant en tout
cas j'aime bien vos émissions
c'est bien regardez vous êtes filmé par
des stars maintenant
mais même flouté la caméra dérange
si les policiers avaient été tatillons
ils auraient mis un PV mais ils ont
d'autres chats à fouetter direction le
quartier du Plateau l'une des zones
chaudes en matière de trafic de cannabis
dans le nord de Paris
en septembre les policiers de Creil ont
mené un joli coup de filet là c'est
là-bas où était fait le gros trafic
dessus dernièrement là c'est là-bas
juste après le bar et si là où ils
avaient installé un système de
Drive pour du cannabis un drive comme
chez McDo 10 heures par jour sans
décembre de voiture une centaine de
clients venaient faire leurs courses
chiffre d'affaires quotidien 3000 euros
c'est un des gros point de villes de la
région disons que tout est lié les gens
n'ont pas de travail pour la plupart
créer quand même une des villes les plus
pauvres en France et bah derrière il
cherche une économie parallèle donc le
shit c'est de l'argent facile la drogue
dure ils veulent pas y toucher et ils
estiment que le shit
c'est un bon moyen de se faire de
l'argent sans prendre trop de risques
quoi voilà
exemple qu'on crée un peu plus loin au
pied d'une autre bar d'immeuble là c'est
en train de vendre tu vois
une voiture blanche est transformée en
supérette à
inutile de s'arrêter les dealers sont
prudents ils n'ont jamais ni drogue ni
argent ni armes sur eux plus on est
présent et plus ça les embête
il y aura de l'offre c'est comme
n'importe quel marché
disons que c'est des problèmes sur
lesquels on arrive encore à travailler
il est les volets FRAX se produisent
quand même beaucoup moins souvent que la
vente de stup
le vol est FRAC pour effraction un
cambriolage quoi et le sucre
de stupéfiants on va partir au Braquo le
braquage un passage quasi obligé pour
avoir les moyens d'investir dans le
cannabis
ça c'est le jeu du chat et de la souris
personne ne parle dans ces quartiers en
fait par peur de représailles la voiture
qui brûle la porte dégradée
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là au commissariat
bureau de la brigade de protection des
familles
les deux officiers en convoqué une jeune
femme qui serait c'est ce qu'on leur a
dit en danger
donc on va attendre de savoir si elle
vient
c'est un voisin qui a entendu des cris
et qui l'a signalé à la police mais
aucune trace de la jeune femme elle
n'est pas au rendez-vous elle répond
critères de la femme battue vu que
en général ce qui se présente pas nous
c'est souvent les victimes de violence
les plus importantes une victime
supposée qui ne répond pas à une
convocation c'est toujours inquiétant
les policiers lancent une petite enquête
de voisinage
mais il y a plus de chance qu'on est sur
lui que sur elle et ça m'ennuie celui du
travail pas elle travaille
TV 202 effectifs de la blpf seront
pour une enquête de voisinage suite à
une affaire de violence conjugale
148 femmes sont mortes en France en 2012
sous les coups de leur conjoint une mort
tous les trois jours
l'isolement la peur la honte la
dépendance financière ou affective les
victimes en toutes les raisons de ce
terme
visiblement l'immeuble vide en tout cas
toutes les portes restent closes
l'éternel loi du silence on se méfie de
la police on a peur des représailles
[Musique]
nos deux policiers repartent bredouille
et un peu frustré
même le principal témoin celui qui a
alerté la police est introuvable
j'appelle la police quand il y a un
souci mais quand il s'agit d'être
auditionné maintenant il y a plus
personne ce dossier est un cas d'école
elle est venue une fois en 2012 et puis
depuis elle est toujours venue déposer
des mains courantes en disant cette
fois-ci je dépose enfin je fais une
déclaration de main courante la
prochaine fois je viendrai déposer
plainte et depuis 2012 on n'a jamais
revu elle fait que des mains courantes
à l'appel de SAMU pour des violences
qu'elle a subi le SAMU appelle un
renfort la patrouille qui intervient et
au vu du salut de la patrouille elle se
rétraque en disant je veux te suivre
hospitalisé parce que je suis blessé
sans préciser pourquoi et refuse
l'intervention de la police ou bien
parce que la part de son conjoint ou
parce que tout simplement parce qu'on
s'apparer il y a toujours un lien qui se
plaint entre la victime et puis son
les policiers parviennent à contacter la
jeune femme un nouveau rendez-vous est
pris pour le surlendemain à 10 heures
moi je continue ma ronde dans les rues
de l'agglomération de Creil en France on
fume chaque année pétard après pétard
250 tonnes de cannabis un trafic qui
rapporte environ un milliard d'euros
et je me rends compte que plus que la
police c'est la caméra qui dérange là
par contre c'est vraiment bien
là on va prendre un truc
donc je pense que si on repasse on sera
on prendra un ou deux projets
moi vaut mieux fermer la fenêtre
et si la caméra c'est uniquement la
caméra c'est juste la caméra parce que
c'est un endroit où on passe tous les
jours et franchement c'est il y a des
moments où on s'arrête et on discute de
temps en temps avec eux ils sont pas non
plus
les monstres
ah bah c'est des gens comme tout le
monde
s'attaquer au réseau de trafiquants en
planquant en enquêtant c'est le boulot
de la police judiciaire pas des hommes
du GSP e il traque la partie visible du
trafic la vente au quotidien dans cette
cité et ailleurs on essaie de repérer
les voitures qui viennent des autres
quartiers les gens qu'on a pas
l'habitude de voir on essaie de voir si
on peut voir leur comportement voir à
quel endroit ils se rendent dans la cité
s'ils se rendent vers un point de villes
ou s'ils se rendent chez de la famille
ou autre
un endroit où il y a un petit peu de
trafic dessus
on va aller voir
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
pas de produits stupéfiants
consommateurs il a l'air bien inoffensif
notre suspect du matin pourtant il
répond parfaitement au profil des
clients qui fréquentent les dealers du
plateau jeune de la région sans
forcément être de créer
bref c'est un consommateur lambda
même pas une petite boulette de Chine
Bruno et Franck reprennent leur ronde
conscient que leur présence ne change
pas grand chose à la très bonne santé du
marché des individus sont condamnés pour
des trafics de stupéfiants toujours des
gens qui apprennent la place mais dans
le jour voir deux jours plus tard
[Musique]
et qui prend place en fait
c'est c'est un petit peu ça c'est que
dès qu'il y en a qui sont topés pour du
trafic de stup il y a toujours un une
voir plusieurs personnes qui sont là
pour remplacer c'est dès qu'ils savent
qu'il y a une place vacances en fait
c'est simple on a déjà contrôler un
travail économique
depuis 8 ans
donc c'est que voilà après ils
connaissait l'adresse ils connaissent
l'endroit là on est près d'une nationale
donc pour eux c'est tout bénef ils
achètent leur conso prennent la
nationale et puis
c'est parti pour certains la vente de
cannabis et la porte d'entrée dans le
grand banditisme
ici à Creil lastar le mythe c'est
Redouane Faïd braqueurs accusé du
meurtre d'une policière municipale en
2010 roi de l'évasion il a grandi sur le
plateau
retour au commissariat avec police
secours 216
tu vas de rue
pas de dégradation dans une cave
commissaire
adjointe de sécurité réceptionne les
appels du 17 oui c'est bon les collègues
sont intervenus on a contrôler le
chauffeur la police bonjour
[Musique]
la police bonjour
oui que puis-je faire pour vous
laser quel laser
[Musique]
que la les appels 17 c'est pour des
appels au secours donc vos appels on
s'en passera d'accord au revoir donc si
ça continue on fera une procédure contre
vous
au standard du 17 police secours de
Creil écoute et filtre 2000 appels par
mois ici s'exprime toute la misère
sociale
madame ok je peux l'avoir au téléphone
j'en peux plus faut le faire dégriser ou
tout ce que vous voulez on peut pas le
ramener avec nous madame nous on va
essayer d'arranger la situation régler
le différent mais on ramènera pas avec
nous il a droit de voir chez lui ce
monsieur ici et ça va les appels moi
c'est pareil les personnes la seule
solution qu'ils ont-ils 17 pour tout dès
qu'il y a pas de solution possible on
fait le 17 après nous on explique si
c'est civil ou pénal mais la première
solution des personnes c'est le 17 à
l'étage séance de mise sous scellé des
ordinateurs saisis chez un cambrioleurs
partent au tribunal en a un les objets
du délice sont référencés et emballés
[Musique]
[Rires]
combien sont-ils ces ordinateurs qui
prennent la poussière dans les placards
des tribunaux quant à récupérer des
véhicules saisies c'est tellement
compliqué qu'en 8 ans dans toute la
France seuls quelques voitures de
malfrat ont rejoint la police
[Musique]
fin de journée retour au standards
partir vite pour prendre en flag les
cambrioleurs
on sait jamais
est-ce qu'ils ont des infos s'ils
veulent du mouvement à l'intérieur ou
pas c'est aussi à cause des cambriolages
que crahes s'est retrouvé en zone de
sécurité prioritaire
sur place police
[Musique]
tout peut basculer rapidement
ce soir il n'y a aucune trace
d'effraction
c'est un animal qui a fait déclencher la
larme ou quelqu'un qui s'éteint
introduire à l'intérieur en priori c'est
pas fouillé
peut-être pas eu le temps ça
m'intervenir rapidement
ça donne un sentiment de puissance
les jeunes qui sont au coin il y en a
quelques-uns qui arrivent vers vous voir
ce que vous faites
[Musique]
on est en alerte ici en fait
est-ce qu'il te frappe au quotidien
[Musique]
qui est tombé un bout de poutre qui est
tombé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le commissaire d'Alta vulve
m'a invité à déjeuner dans un bistrot où
il a ses habitudes
donc là c'est votre chez Jany comme
bureau c'est l'annexe de votre bureau
[Musique]
on est en dehors de la circonscription
ah oui d'accord
en fait on est chez Simenon
[Musique]
bonjour ça va et vous ça va bien merci
ah oui c'est
c'est
l'annexe on dirait un truc du
commissaire Maigret
c'est incroyable vous avez votre petite
salle à manger
dans ce décor à la Maigret on pourrait
croiser aussi les tontons flingueurs
le commissaire paltavul m'explique sa
vision du métier et sa recette pour que
les crayons un puissent vivre et dormir
en paix la bague c'est une composante
incontournable c'est un recours c'est
des fonctionnaires qui sont sportifs qui
sont très volontaires mais c'est qu'une
toute petite facette du travail de
police telle qui doit se concevoir un
travail de paix public dans des
quartiers qui
certes sont difficiles mais qui sont des
lieux de vie de plein d'habitants de
plein de gens très fortes avec une
sociologie très forte et ces gens ont le
droit à la tranquillité sécurité de la
même manière que les autres et pas
uniquement par une présence de type bac
il faut qu'il croise aussi du il faut
qu'il voit de la police quand ça se
passe bien c'est moi mon message auprès
de mes effectifs c'est qu'on soit banal
je veux qu'on soit banal dans le paysage
on met partout on doit être partout tout
le temps le plus possible et aussi et
surtout quand ça se passe bien c'est à
dire il faut pas rentrer dans les cités
que quand il y a une difficulté il faut
y être il faut que ce soit un passage
normal pour une patrouille police
secours mais parfois
peut ressembler à provocation ça peut
finalement que parfois votre présence
créer un problème tout à fait il y a un
côté dramatisant dans l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre notamment si elle est
exceptionnelle
un peu de réconfort merci merci
[Musique]
sans filet on n'a pas de compagnie
départementale d'intervention qui va
venir à notre secours
un quart d'heure plus tard donc c'est
voilà en résumé c'est moins dur la
situation et la taille des cités est
moindre cadeau de endroits mais le fait
qu'on travaille sans renfort ça exige
beaucoup plus de
d'investissements personnel de courage
et de maîtrise de soi de la part des
policiers de terrain c'est quelque chose
dégénère
en émeutes ou quelque chose de vraiment
massif vous pouvez compter que sur vous
oui c'est pour ça que tous les tous les
fonctionnaires du qui arrive au
commissariat quel que soit leur profil
bénéficier d'une petite formation au
maintien de l'ordre qu'il est prépare au
fait que un fonctionnaire qui a affecté
à la prise de plainte au commissariat de
Creil sur un simple ding dong dans le
commissariat il peut 20 minutes plus
tard se retrouver avec le casque le
bouclier les équipements de protection
en train de faire du maintien de l'ordre
bonjour
puisque les violences urbaines ne
viennent pas à moi et c'est tant mieux
je vais à elle trop costaud ça le
problème
tous les policiers des commissariats
sont capables de faire ça ils doivent
l'être et régulièrement on a des
recyclables
je commence à comprendre pourquoi les
policiers mettent toujours les mains
comme ça parce qu'en fait c'est
l'endroit où on peut mettre ses mains
[Musique]
de plaisanterie action
la manœuvre allez extraire un fauteur de
trouble en milieu
on va aller interpeler mon visite
une fois la cible maîtrisée Europe les
tactique pour se mettre à l'abri
comment vous êtes sortis dans le dispo
pas mal le tout est de pas sortir du
cadre bouclier quoi
et maintenant faisons parler la poudre
votre objectif ce sera de rentrer par la
fenêtre avec le mur blanc
la visée est super idée quoi on va
passer ce qu'on appelle le ça nous fait
à balancer tout ce qu'il a Crimo
de puissance
j'aurais dû faire attention au vent le
gaz lacrymo nous revient droit dessus
s'entraîner est essentiel pour les
policiers de Creil le commissariat est
isolé en cas d'émote les premiers
renforts mettent au moins 40 minutes à
arriver
à se tenir
début de soirée la bague de nuit
commençant
on va au plateau donc quartier sensible
de Creil apparemment un requérant nous a
appelé pour parce qu'il aperçu des
individus qui rentraient une une moto
donc peut-être voler dans un dans un box
ou un garage
de nuit comme de jour le plateau reste
la cité qu'il ne faut pas lâcher
après avoir recueilli quelques
renseignements dans les cages d'escalier
c'est dans une cave que la BAC retrouve
la moto et quelques petites surprises
le cocktail Moloto de préparer donc il
nous faudrait une patrouille PS
effectivement avec des gants je trouve
et un sac plastique pour pouvoir les
mettre dedans ouais c'est reçu mon
équipe a un véhicule
pour le secteur CRÉO pour moi c'est le
quartier le plus le plus chaud de créer
le policier avait juste des jeunes
commencent à se regrouper donc là celui
qui est au téléphone il vient d'avertir
notre présence là
205 TV 205 de TV 203
donc les jeunes qui sont au coin il y en
a quelques-uns qui arrivent vers vous
voir ce que vous faites
dans les caves depuis longtemps laissé à
l'abandon les policiers récupèrent avec
précaution les cocktails prêts à
l'emploi
ça fait deux trois jours on est on est
en alerte ici en fait donc à mon avis ce
soir c'était guet-apens
les 8 bouteilles n'attendaient plus
qu'une allumette pour prendre feu
les cocktails ont sans doute été
confectionnés sur place
à l'extérieur chacune des parties
observe le jeu de l'autre
[Musique]
son devoir pourquoi on est là ou si
c'est eux pour la moto savoir ce qu'on
va faire à 204 écoute
[Musique]
4 à 5 individus puis plus curieux
qu'autre chose ils sont sur une voiture
ils regardent donc pour l'instant c'est
comme
en sous-sol la collecte des indices
continue dans cette bouteille en
plastique les sens qui a servi à
confectionner les Molotov
je vais aller chercher la moto
la moto est saisie elle aussi elle était
sans doute destinée à être incendié pour
attirer la police
mais ce soir le piège ne fonctionne pas
[Musique]
au poste la découverte des cocktails est
prise très au sérieux pour le
commissaire paltavul il ne s'agit pas
d'un simple jeu de sales gosses les
mauvais signaux s'accuma
en revanche
on a un message d'Amérique qui nous
signale que
d'après les échos du quartier ça peut
être tendu ce week-end dans la mesure du
possible sans trop s'exposer on y va et
on fait des prisonniers on n'est pas
totalement serein là parce que on n'a
pas on sent quoi qu'il y a il y a
quelque chose d'irrationnel dans tout ça
c'est une lutte constante pour que les
lois s'appliquent partout et puis que
certains se privatisent pas des espaces
publics
donc crayon dormi les voitures de police
reprennent leur ronde et retournent sur
le plateau
[Musique]
à la recherche d'éventuelles
incendiaires à la recherche du flagrant
délit
o
[Musique]
qui sera en train de s'étendre à un
pavillon pas d'affolement on a pu pas
sur le champignon on est plutôt calme ça
n'est jamais qu'en feu de voiture la
routine de toute façon il n'y a plus
rien à faire la voiture est perdue gare
et loin elle ne représente pas de danger
[Musique]
les pompiers entre en scène on ne
connaîtra probablement jamais ni les
auteurs ni les causes de cette incendie
[Musique]
le jour est levé depuis quelques heures
retour à l'étage de la brigade des
familles
un proche de la jeune femme victime de
violences conjugales c'est manifestée il
vient témoigner
l'audition du beau-père est essentielle
il faut essayer de cerner le degré
d'urgence et savoir si le beau-père est
ou non le témoin direct de ces violences
quelle relation vous entretenez avec
elle
avant par rapport au décalage de pluie
bon c'est plus la même à la changer
quand à chaque fois quand elle vient
c'est par rapport au pascalier c'est
comme là c'est fait frappé ou peut-être
engueuler par son copain et à vers la
maison pour
vous est-ce que les victimes de violence
de la part de Monsieur
une fois elle est venue à la maison j'ai
parlé avec eux parce qu'ils sont
engueulés dedans ils sont repartis une
heure après ils doivent taper un coup de
prenait en œil et je l'ai retrouvé à
l'hôpital mais après tout dépend comment
il est parce que lui-même il a été
violent avec ses parents il est un peu
comme je vous dis un jeu avec comme ça
comment jouer avec son cerveau il peut
se tromper et quand il se trompe sur sa
cerveau voilà c'est il peut être un peu
dangereux pour elle
d'accord malheureusement ce témoignage
ne fait pas beaucoup avancer les choses
voilà je veux voir accompagner
le beau-père a bien décrit un homme
imprévisible et un climat conflictuel
mais il n'apporte pas le témoignage
décisif et ce dossier n'est pas le seul
le travail à la brigade des familles ne
manque pas
il y a quoi là en gros en gros c'est
quoi le en gros je veux dire
80% de dossiers violence conjugale
un petit peu de violence scolaire et
puis une dizaine de pour cent de
d'affaires sexuel sans mineur donc
ça peut attendre combien de temps
finalement entre le moment où une dame
vient vous dire mon mari me bat
théorique maintenant
Ronald dossier on convoque l'auteur dans
la semaine il est convoqué
sur un préliminaire donc on va la
relancer
on peut avoir du retard on peut pas se
louper sur une affaire faut absolument
qu'on pressante la faire sensible qu'on
laisse pas passer parce que ça pourrait
être aller jusqu'au drame
c'est l'humeur des victimes ou y compris
l'auteur
il y a un contexte un auteur peut-être
qu'à TV victime de violence quand il
était enfant qui reproduit il y a le
contexte puis bien souvent l'auteur est
provoqué par la victime ou même les
victimes de violence réciproque et les
bagarres dans le couple enfin bon il y a
il y a tout ça c'est pas c'est peut-être
le retard c'est peut-être aussi une
personne en détresse
l'auteur je ne le verrai jamais en
revanche la victime à elle doit arriver
d'un instant à l'autre
la voilà des proches l'ont prévenu que
la police la cherche elle se présente en
fin le major Dauchy va procéder à son
audition aujourd'hui c'est parce que je
vois que tu vis dans la crainte et que
tu es victime de violence est-ce qu'il
te frappe au quotidien
[Musique]
c'est pas lui avoir envie de te frapper
c'est pas mais c'est pas normal ce que
tu me dis tu imagines il me frappe quand
il en a envie
[Musique]
le major douche tente de sortir la jeune
fille de Center
tu peux pas continuer à vivre comme ça
c'est impossible tu as dû quitter ton
travail à cause de lui tu vis tous les
jours dans la crainte et victimes de
violence tu peux tu peux même pas d'amis
je peux aussi
[Musique]
toujours tout seul le major comprend que
la jeune femme est sous l'emprise totale
de son compagnon
en fait il s'en prend pour moi aimer
tout s'énerve sûrement il découvre moi
ce que je veux savoir c'est s'il te
frappe régulièrement
j'ai l'impression que tu as tendance à
minimiser qu'est-ce que tu crois
oh mais c'est important moi je sais ce
que ce qui se passe
[Musique]
donc quand tu me dis il me donne des
petites claques comme ça une tire les
cheveux je pense qu'il y a plus et qui
veut pas m'en parler
parce qu'en fait je sais que ça je vais
avoir des problèmes avec sa femme je
vais je vais
est-ce que toi tu as l'intention de
déposer plainte contre lui
et pourquoi parce que
[Musique]
par rapport à ça je lui ai promis que
non
en fait tu veux pas que les problèmes là
pour monter un dossier solide le major
de Chi est absolument besoin de fait
précis
donc moi je vais revenir je insiste
parce que je veux pas qu'il est de
soucis mais moi je m'a priorité comme je
t'ai dit c'est que moi je veux pas que
toi tu es de soucis d'accord moi je veux
pas te retrouver un jour dans ton
appartement la tête fracassée parce que
on n'a pas fini nécessaire et parce que
tu as pas voulu qu'il ait des problèmes
donc là il faut que ça sorte mais en
fait moi
je sais pas
je préfère c'est moi
c'est pas ta faute qui arrive comment tu
peux dire ça et pourquoi ce serait ta
faute
c'est de ma faute ça revient jusqu'à
ma faute excuse-moi
il frappe après il demande des excuses
c'est le schéma et c'est en train de me
l'écrire là
[Applaudissements]
mais rien n'y fait comme neuf femmes sur
10 elle renonce sa déposer plainte et
retourne vivre chez son compagnon
l'absence de plainte n'a pas empêché le
procureur de la République de placer le
conjoint en garde à vue il a ordonné une
expertise psychologique
dans l'agglomération de Creil une
cinquantaine de couples font
régulièrement parlé d'eux pris dans un
cercle infernal de violence
d'intervention de la police puis de
retour au calme jusqu'à la prochaine
crise
[Musique]
appel d'urgence un équipage est à la
poursuite d'un suspect qui a pris la
fuite je suis en renfort à bord d'un
fourgon de police secours j'arrive au
quartier de la Commanderie l'un des
points sensibles de la ZSP
une voiture suspecte a essayé de
secourir le fuyard les policiers la
contrôle
vous allez baisser directement
même si la caméra attise les tensions je
sens bien que par principe un contrôle
passe mal vécu comme une énième
provocation une frustration de plus
c'est le système qui fait que voilà les
jeunes sont poussés à bout
c'est le système qui rend les jeunes
comme ça s'il y aurait du travail il y
aura quelque chose on les aide
dans la vie de tous les jours je pense
que tout le monde travaillerait mais il
y en a ils ont des BTS des bac pro des
trop pas de travail fin de contrôle
allez bon courage presque amical
je reprends la ronde avec Franck et
Bruno toujours à la recherche du fuyard
dans la maison là juste la maison là à
droite une blanche et il enchaîne tous
les tous les donc il est là à droite
au moment du contrôle pour qu'il parte
comme ça c'est qu'il doit avoir quelque
chose au cul
quelqu'un de recherche un truc comme ça
quand soudain un appel à la radio
ouais j'ai 293
à l'entrée de la cité où ce serait
réfugié de jeunes rechercher une voiture
de police secours vient de se faire
caillerasser
les policiers veulent mettre la main sur
le jeune qui leur a lancé en pavé en
nombre il se rentre dans la cité quand
surprise je retrouve le jeune à la
voiture blanche contrôlé un peu plus tôt
c'est n'importe quoi si vous avez vu la
scène ils sont venus ils se sont pris à
des petits à des petits
non c'est pas ça vous racontez une
blague quand même non tout à l'heure on
se retrouve dans la Hyundai
changer de voiture mais c'est pas ça
c'est même pas question
du tout c'est c'est rien du tout on sait
même pas on sait même pas pourquoi
tout à l'heure mais on sait même pas on
sait même pas pourquoi il a une fiche
vous êtes allé le chercher avec votre
voiture puis avec une deuxième normal
mais c'est normal
tous les quartiers c'est comme ça on est
solidaire mais c'est aussi normal que la
police fasse en sorte que ça se passe
pas comme ça
le jeu du chat et de la souris ce soir
les chats reviennent bredouille le
fuyard court toujours
en venant ta Creil je m'attendais à des
scènes d'émeutes frôlant la guérilla
urbaine finalement il ne s'est pas passé
grand chose mais durant mon séjour j'ai
pris conscience qu'une simple
altercation un contrôle de police qui
dérape et les quartiers peuvent
s'embraser
il est temps pour moi de repartir vers
de nouveaux horizons à la découverte de
nouveaux hommes et de nouvelles femmes
au métier peu ordinaire
[Musique]